Parliament will vote on the EU Vietnam  trade deal this agreement would increase  European trade opportunities eliminates  barriers and tariffs while opening up  services and public procurement markets  following the UK's departure from the EU  the European Parliament's will set out  its position on the direction of future  relations we are living through an  artificial intelligence revolution MEP s  want to tackle challenges arising from  such technologies and will discuss  measures the EU should take to protect  consumers Parliament will debate the EU  gender equality priorities the  Commission wants to tackle violence  against women eliminates the gender pay  gap and promote work-life balance  Parliament will discuss new proposals to  make the EU enlargement policy more  effective and dynamic last year talks on  opening accession negotiations with  North Macedonia and Albania ended in  deadlock